what's up my fellow gamers that's right
everybody can we get some game early in
the check if we hit 5,000 gamer types
I'm gonna do a special surprise for you
guys so make sure you smash like on the
video this is me I bet you wonder how I
ended up in this situation
my name is tor PA and this is my story
hey guys welcome to my first block oh
Jesus okay so there's a lot of stuff
that I haven't done in this game that
are yet to be explored let's go to the
market shall we I am so frickin hyped
I'm rushing well I keep playing the game
wrong that's for sure
that's kind of cute okay where are you
aha
found you at last hey watch it
wait I know I can do right way wait huh
got you now whamon Oh God hey shield
don't hey hey you're hitting my shield
that's just feel frayed stop you're
hurting her stop it oh gosh darn it
alright we're gonna have to go we're
gonna have to bounce we're gonna have to
bounce this is not what I wanted at all
stop everyone just stops think about
what you're doing you're hurting the
children where am I
you're all fried tomatoes gosh damn it
all right we're gonna have to plan B
Plan B everyone Plan B Plan B it's knee
time baby ah she's barking the knees
they've adapted stop blocking the Nick
he's done ah I got your night stuck in
his knee I need you to stop I need you
to stop listen
why would you just stop how do they keep
spawning I thought this is easy this
games been impossible well that could
have gone better let's get it let's get
a bigger weapon it's freaking spear time
boys yeah this is it's the famous
Swedish things huh oh my god I'm so
sorry oh my god I'm so sorry
god I didn't mean I swear to God I swear
to god man don't come near me don't come
near me
do not [ __ ] Oh
up or down up or down oh oh oh
oh-oh-oh watch for it there it is
goddamn there's so many it's hard to hit
him oh okay I got him I got him okay
okay Kay peace peace peace please oh god
he has friends
god dammit is so goddamn many of them
what am I supposed to do different times
calls for desperate measure means
goddammit stuck it is me it's freaking
stuck in his neck I'm legit trying here
it's so goddamn hard Swedish boy alright
hey hey look this look at this look at
this look at this ha hey hey hey hey
look at this look at this but me me me
what's this what's this me that's nice
get a slice and ass fish good god damn
her so many other high
yah anyone else want some of that cat
dammit alright alright okay okay I need
a drink guys oh oh hold on guys
ah hold on guys just give me this ah ah
it feels so good
is that the last one is that the last
one are you the last one listen we don't
have to fight listen it's just you and
me no one is watching jaysis almost died
in-game life stop fighting
Sabu everyone please please like you
messed with the wrong boy Swedish boy
you'll regret this
you'll regret this daddy and pig daddy
and son is gonna go for a little walk
what's that it's over for you this is it
what's that okay
I don't care what you want another one
okay I don't care daddy and son it's
gonna go in a little adventure aren't
you aren't you excited aren't you
excited tell me how excited you are
it's time Matt tell me where is T
savings tell me where are they tell me
now or no one gets here
[Music]
stop playing
I
[Music]
alright well that was epic boy very
angry oh you did not do that
god they're so goddamn many of them stop
it does not have to be this way it could
be friends we could be lovers we could
be best mates oh you just hit your
friends idiot nice ponytail loser just
sit down sit down
women aren't video games I've been
telling you for millions of years the
evolution did not come to this stop
blocking I swear to God if you park
another I'm almost dead
I'm almost dead uh-huh and not like this
not like this I give up you win you win
I'm sorry
have you heard of the legend of dark
Plagueis the wise oh sorry about that
you're in good hands now mum's here
don't worry daddy pooch is not gonna do
anything bad
give me your weapon what was that you're
sorry
you apologize well that's a little too
late now isn't it now little boy if you
do an epic breakdance I would consider
forgiving you break it down a two-minute
oh wow he's got all kinds of moves
damn you're really good at this all
right go away no stay down he's still
alive don't worry we're just gonna have
to amputate your knees you're King nazar
God there will never walk again
off you go
what do you got Oh two at a time
Oh two at a time now is that how we're
doing it hey hey I got your friend just
pin it up bye-bye sorry sure son
bye-bye now hahahaha oh wow
it looks like I'm totally undefeatable
subscribe to pootie okay I think it's
time to stop you want pyramids we got
him oh you're into castles huh we got
you covered baby you want some bets easy
we got it all this game is still
relevant god damn it